let's bring a national border patrol
council president Brandon Judd on that
front uh Brandon I believe we have you
coming up here there there we go all
right great great to see you uh I think
that this uh Marshall thing this Air
Marshal thing is going to come as a
surprise to a lot of people
um you have hundreds of Air Marshals
being taken from their posts these are
trained guys being sent to the southern
border to do what's being described as
humanitarian work during the busiest
travel period of the year what do you
make of this
yeah this is absolutely crazy this is
the typical robbing Peter to pay Paul
for failures of this uh secretary you
can't destabilize one agency and expect
that you're going to be able to continue
to protect the American people
um we expect that there's going to be
Air Marshals in the air to ensure that
another 911 doesn't happen and now that
you're taking people out of the field
um you're you're sending the clear
message that it's it's now open season
to uh to look at air traffic as a means
to uh harm the American public you can't
do this and the other thing that you
have to look at is it really doesn't
matter whether we have Air Marshals or
not when you look at that statement from
DHS that they're creating a safe and
orderly immigration system that is
absolutely false what we're seeing right
now is anything but orderly what we're
seeing right now is anything but Humane
everything that they're doing
um clearly shows the clearly um sends a
message to the cartels that that they
can do whatever that they want and and
people can cross the border we are not
enforcing our laws right now so even if
you have the Air Marshals down there um
as long as we apprehend people and
continue to release them into the United
States we are not enforcing our laws
we're not creating a safe and orderly
immigration system this Administration
has clearly failed as far as border
security goes it's absolutely a
free-for-all right now on our borders
yeah the fact Brandon that this is
coming from DHS the Department of
Homeland Security the department was
created after 9 11. now you have
mayorcus sending Air Marshals to the
Border taking them away from their posts
to to do what they weren't trained for
administrative and humanitarian work so
how far have we really come over the
past 21 years since 9 11 happened and
also so where is he on that and also
where's Transportation secretary Pete
Buda judge you have to wonder if he's
pushing back on this as well
we obviously haven't learned anything
from from our past failures from past
experiences and like you said where is
Pete budijig why is he allowing DHS to
pull people out of his
um Department to to again destabilize
one law enforcement agency just to try
to help another law enforcement agency
when in reality you're not doing
anything for the border patrol by
bringing these people over we have got
to have policies and programs that is
what's going to secure the Border not um
pulling more people from One agency over
to another agency if we had the proper
policies and programs we could in fact
secure the Border you know the problem
is is the the other night I was uh I was
on a midnight shift and every single one
of our agents we were performing
administrative duties rather than
patrolling the Border you can't do that
and expect that we're going to stop the
criminal cartels from bringing across
our fentanyl criminal aliens or aliens
from special interest countries got to
do our job Fentanyl and Fentanyl killed
70 one thousand Americans in 2021 and
2022 already killed 75 000 Americans and
now you have these Narcan vending
machines narcan's the drug that will
reverse the effects of fentanyl so
hopefully people don't die these Narcan
vending machines are popping up in
cities in small towns across the country
one small town of seven thousand people
was forced to re-talk seven times in one
month alone is this a sign of just how
bad this fentanyl crisis is getting
this is basically giving up this is
basically saying that we're not going to
do anything to stop these drugs from
coming in you know the novel idea is
don't put these in the machine let's
stop the drugs from coming coming across
our Southwest border but if if we
continue to do this all we're doing is
putting a Band-Aid on the problem we
have got to go in and we have got to go
after the criminal cartels we have got
to go after their Enterprise we've got
to go after their profits and if we were
to do that we would save the lives of of
thousands of American citizens on a
daily basis instead what we're doing is
we're clearly showing the the American
people that they that this
Administration does not care about their
lives their safety
um and and the security of everybody
here in the United absolutely right it
would be better not to have the fentanyl
in the country to begin with than need
these vending machines at all Brandon
thank you so much for joining us
thank you Carly appreciate it I'm Steve
Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis